[Musica]
bene se pensavate che io vi avrei
parlato di questi diamanti sbagliavate
noi siamo geologi scusate siamo geologi
ma facciamo due errori siamo geologi
siamo gente un po strana e a noi
piacciono questi diamanti questi sono
pieni di inclusione impurezze gli amanti
che non mettereste mai al dito
ovviamente ma perché noi piacciono
questi diamanti per siamo pazzi
oltre a questo il vero motivo è che
grazie a questi diamanti recentemente
abbiamo scoperto che alle grandi
profondità del nostro pianeta ci sono
accenni di acqua e oggi vi farò capire
come siamo arrivati a questa grande
scoperta scientifica la nostra storia
inizia nel 1869 e questa storia vi farà
capire come un cristallino piccolo
piccolo di 0,04 mm ha cambiato tutto
quello che sapevamo del nostro pianeta
un cristallino trappolato dentro un
diamante per milioni di anni
ok la nostra storia inizia nel
queensland siamo in australia in un
piccolo paesino chiamato tenham febbraio
1869 di notte
cadono ben 102 meteoriti proprio su
teheran
da quel momento quelle meteoriti
verranno chiamate le meteoriti di tenham
1935 le meteoriti vengono donate in
blocco al british museum di londra
e pensate esattamente cento anni dopo il
loro ritrovamento quindi nel 1969
i tre geologi beans davis reed
pubblicano sull'autorevole rivista
nature's un importantissima scoperta
scientifica che riguardava proprio le
meteoriti di te nun ma cos'è che avevano
scoperto questi tre geologi avevano
scoperto che un minerale molto
importante chiamato olivina un silicato
di ferro magnesio silicio
che costituiva le m di te nun si
trasformava in un altro minerale fino
allora sconosciuto con la stessa
composizione chimica e una densità
maggiore che loro avevano chiamato ring
udite tenete a mente questo nome ring
udite dal famoso geologo australiano the
drain good bene perché avveniva questa
trasformazione a causa degli impatti
nello spazio che questi metodi ti
subivano prima di cadere sulla terra ma
perché questa scoperta la cosa
importante da finire sul national due
motivi il primo come sanno i miei
studenti di geologia e qualcuno in sala
l'olivina costituisce il 60 per cento
del nostro pianeta fino a 410 chilometri
di profondità non lo sapevate
quindi noi camminiamo su l'olivina
viviamo sulla divina
quindi era importante per noi
il secondo motivo è qui il geologo
diventa curioso era ma se questa
trasformazione che avveniva nello spazio
a causa degli impatti avvenisse anche
all'interno della terra
e beh qui si sarebbe aperto uno scenario
nuovo
perché quei tempi noi non sapevamo nulla
di quello che potesse esserci
all'interno della terra e questa era una
prova diretta che forse la pressione
poteva aiutare ma come rispondere a
questa domanda la trivellazione più
profonda che l'uomo ha fatto sulla terra
non arriva neanche a 12 km e il raggio
terrestre 6.000 374 km ebbene ci siamo
messi a costruire delle strane presse
gigantesche come quella che vedete in
figura che generano pressioni e
temperature elevatissime ma in
laboratorio e quindi pensate comprimendo
proprio un olivina la nostra beneamata
olivina ad una pressione corrispondente
a 600 km di profondità
sapete cosa si trasformava in rim pulite
proprio quella in gu dite che i tre
geologi hanno trovato nelle mete di
ditte nam bingo allora possiamo
sintetizzare tutta la terra
e così facemmo utilizzando queste presse
iniziamo sintetizzare tutta una serie di
minerali che probabilmente costituivano
al nostro pianeta e vedete quella fetta
colorata con tutti quei colori sulla sua
superficie beh quella è la struttura
interna della terra manca soltanto il
nucleo che fatto di fare uniche che non
più ecco bene dovete capire che quella
struttura interna della terra la
conosciamo solo grazie agli esperimenti
fatti laboratorio e poniamoci una
domanda però questo punto è se fosse
tutto sbagliato e se tutti gli
esperimenti fatti laboratorio in realtà
non rappresentassero il nostro pianeta
bene non sarebbe bello per noi non
sapremmo neanche cosa c'è all'interno
della terra
e allora per rispondere a questa domanda
e tu che arrivano i miei amati diamanti
dovrà sapere che gli amanti sono gli
unici materiali terrestri che viaggiano
nel tempo sono vecchi fino a 3,5
miliardi di anni
la terra 4,5 4,6 miliardi anni e nello
spazio
questi arrivano da grandissime
profondità fino alla superficie
senz'anima senza essere distrutti e
quando siamo fortunati al loro interno
come vedete in questa immagine
all'interno vedremo i puntini neri quei
colori strani allora interno possiamo
trovare delle inclusioni che cosa sono
queste delusioni sono dei frammenti di
terra profonda sono dei pezzi reali del
nostro pianeta a grandi profondità e su
questo che si basava lohan idea studiamo
quanti più di amanti possibile per
capire se tutti quegli esperimenti fatti
laboratorio e di alta coincidevano
davvero quello che c'è all'interno della
terra e grazie al finanziamento di un
eps council abbiamo potuto a sembrare
uno strumento prototipo che funziona con
i raggi ics e studia i diamanti o meglio
le loro inclusioni all'interno dei
diamanti inclusioni
bellissime e grazie a questi strumenti
nel 2014
studiando un diamante brasiliano pagato
non più di 10 dollari al suo interno
abbiamo trovato un'inclusione
piccolissima di quei famosi 0,04 mm e
sapete cos'era ring udite la prima ring
udite terrestre questo vuol dire che
quel diamante proveniva da almeno 600 km
profondità benissimo ma la scoperta più
importante non era la ring udite era
quello che c'era dentro quella lingua di
te in quella di mou di te
abbiamo trovato 1,4 per cento di acqua a
quelle profondità inaspettatamente quale
l'implicazione a semplice guardate
questa fetta di terra noi geologi
tagliamo ogni volta a fette il nostro
pianeta una cosa che ci piace molto
guardate quella fascia azzurrina che si
chiama zona di transizione quella fascia
è costituita dal 35 per cento proprio di
ringu di te e facciamo un calcolo
velocissimo salary nudità e corrisponde
al 35 per cento della zona di
transizione e contiene 1,4 per cento di
acqua
sapete cosa vuol dire che nella zona di
transizione abbiamo un contenuto d'acqua
pari a 3 4 volte l'oceano pacifico e
allora il contenuto d'acqua sulla terra
è molto ma molto più grande di quello
che noi pensavano certo voi potreste
dire e nestola un cristallo di cointreau
patronimici un diamante un continente e
questo rappresenterebbe tutta la terra
di tre giorni ma noi siamo tosti
testardi e via studiati tanti altri gli
amanti abbiamo stato di avanti dall
africa che venivano da profonda molto
maggiori 90 100 carati di cristalli e
sapete cosa c'era dentro quegli amanti
c'erano inclusioni metalliche con
intorno idrogeno metano fatta un altra
parte del mondo di nuovo l'idrogeno
quindi
fatemi concludere con una piccola
speranza quello che vedete un ciclo
dell'acqua semplificato globale del
nostro pianeta
dovete sapere che il ciclo dell'acqua
quindi tutte le previsioni si basa su
cosa anche sul contenuto di acqua totale
che c'è sul nostro pianeta
e beh ma allora vuol dire che tutti i
cicli dell'acqua che dovranno essere
ricalcolati in futuro si dovranno basare
proprio su questo nuovo contenuto
d'acqua che abbiamo scoperto negli
ultimi anni e speriamo che i dati che
verranno fuori dai prossimi cicli
saranno un po più positivi di quello che
abbiamo adesso è con questo ringrazio
[Applauso]